westbrook has it  westbrook drives gets to the basket this  thing bounces and finally falls  [Applause]  [Music]  russell westley drives gets to the  basket and scores  backs up against corey joseph  westbrook justin in the shot and sticks  it  104.98  russell westbrook  click to the basket for a jam oh my  goodness vintage  and look at jeremy grant he never saw  him the only guy who saw him was hamadou  diallo  anthony davis with a rebound  pistons with a four-point lead seven  minutes left westbrook for three rattles  it home  dribbled hard at him backed him off and  then elevated nothing davis could do  westbrook with the hook pass  from davis  outside to carmelo anthony  they drop it down to davis  westbrook cuts and scores what westbrook  did was  jeremy grant in this situation you might  become a good decoy because if they're  coming for him